while the world is still buzzing over  the birth of beyoncé and jay-z's twins  mr. Carter stepped out for a little  exercise he was spotted for the first  time since the babies were born leaving  a Los Angeles SoulCycle and just look at  that smile that is one proud papa Jay's  got plenty to be happy about  as if caring for two newborn babies  wasn't enough the rapper and mogul also  announced he is dropping his thirteenth  studio album 444 exclusively on title  and four sprint users on Friday he gave  fans a sneak peak with this teaser clip  featuring Danny Glover and Amer Herschel  Olly letter to my dad that I never broke  speeches I prepared that I never spoke  this next era of jay-z also means a new  moniker that's right a rep for his  company rock nation confirmed a  pitchfork he added the - back in his  name and is using all caps  [Music]  you